nous sommes en l'an 1977 la sonde
américaine voyageurs a quitté le sol
terrestre pour un périple à travers le
vide spatial
aujourd'hui soit 43 ans plus tard elle a
déjà quitté le système solaire évoque à
dix-huit mille milliards de kilomètres
de son berceau
c'est désormais l'artefact d'origine
humaine le plus loin tant de nous c'est
surtout un témoin émouvant de la soif de
connaissance et d'exploration qui
animent l'être humain le regard tourné
vers le ciel vers un ailleurs porteur de
tous les fantasmes
tous les rêves tous les espoirs
par contre pour savoir ce qu'elles sont
nos pieds là y'a plus personne c'est
facile de regarder ce qu'il ya dans
l'espace ou dans l'assiette d'angelina
jolie ou dans une vidéo d'y penser on
regarde et on voit qu'il ya rien alors
que si on veut savoir ce qu'a à
l'intérieur de la terre on a comme un
petit souci c'est que mère nature
n'était pas vitryat et comme je me le
disait en me réveillant hier matin à 15
heures si l'espace est plein de vides
les roches elles sont vides de pleins ça
ne veut rien dire mais ça a l'air
profond un peu comme le forage de colas
qu'on embrasse cola pas son forage n'est
pas encore assez c'est le trou le plus
profond qu'on ait creusé 12 km et des
brouettes il est situé en russie et oui
c'est ce qu'ils font les russes ils vont
dans l'espace ils annexent la crimée et
kroos détruit ce forage de colas a été
commencée en 1970 donc avant le départ
de la sonde voyageurs même si ça n'a
absolument rien à voir et il aura duré
près de vingt ans vingt ans pour creuser
12 km à la base ils voulaient descendre
plus bas mais il avait mal anticipé
plein de trucs comme la pression et la
chaleur aussi bas et l'attention sur
l'ex de foire à tout le monde s'en fout
mais ça m'intéresse donc qu'ils ont dû
abandonner en cours de route
et oui c'est ce qu'ils font les russes
il abandonne ils abandonnent leurs
principes en implantant des mcdo sur
leur territoire il abandonne le droit à
la propriété en faveur du collectivisme
et il en charge zone sexuelle si vous
êtes russe j'ai qu'une chose abouti saft
halak 12 km c'est un record mondial ils
ont traversé le tiers de la croûte
terrestre en parlant de kout vous
connaissez la différence entre les
l'épreuve il reste encore plus de 6000
kilomètres à parcourir pour arriver au
centre de la terre ma mère m'a toujours
dit dans mon enfance sa part d'une bonne
intention mais c'est pas une bonne idée
de repeindre le chat avec son veau ou en
l'occurrence de creuser pour essayer de
savoir si la terre renferme en son coeur
un choeur extra moelleux comme les
cookies granola à l'huile de palme
alors comment faire pour commencer on
peut demander aux philosophes ils ont ça
va rien non plus le jour assure mais il
pense toute la journée c'est leur métier
et des fois à force de réfléchir très
très très fort et balzac ou jdidé alors
bon on va leur laisser une chance l'un
des premiers en avoir eu des idées sur
la question en tout cas en occident ces
roulements de tambour aristote quand il
avait fini de compter les pattes des
mouches aidant des femmes
il s'est mis à imaginer une espèce de
théorie des éléments comme les pokémon
feu air ball paillasson sauce soja
groupe électro rock pour aristote la
terre était formé de l'élémentaire mon
chat watts à cette couche de terre est
entourée d'eau puis des bruits d'une
couche de fond donc c'est un peu comme
si un salamèche avait bouffé 1
cool qui lui-même avait gobé un quart à
puce qui lui-même manger de la terre et
c'est cette vision qui a perduré pendant
toute l'antiquité et le moyen âge en
occident aristote émission et puis après
bon alors il ya des explorations vasco
de gama magellan gérard collomb tout ça
et des nouveaux paradigmes qui sont
arrivés vous savez quand copernic a dit
que la terre le soleil en fait c'est pas
parce que vous croyez là dessus dans ce
grand chamboulement cosmique ce bond
rené descartes s'est senti un peu
pousser des ailes et il a voulu lui
aussi disrupt et nous sommes en l'an en
1644 descartes a fini de dissocier le
corps et l'esprit
mais il lui reste encore un peu de
poussière d'étoilés un soir il s'est
fait un bon gros trip au coin du feu et
il s'est dit mais hey les mecs en fête
la terre c'est un ancien soleil ouais
elle était corsé leur poussière d'étoilé
à l'époque du coup pour lui ni encore un
vieux restes de soleil au milieu de
notre planète l'appui d'autres couches
au tour notamment une couche de terre
bien bien tassés une couche d'eau une
couche d'air une couche de terre -
tassée qui flottent au dessus du reste
un peu comme un pro bowl mais cette
couche là elle est séché par le soleil
le vrai et du coup elle fondit comme
dans le roi lui ai alors là il ya des
miettes qui vont tomber au fond et alors
ils vont rebondir dans l'eau et galons
qui va remonter en surface
et paf c'est ça qui va nous faire les
rivières et les océans je vous avais dit
qu'ils pensaient beaucoup beaucoup ces
philosophes des professionnels de la
pensée n'essayez pas de reproduire
sachez donc non seulement ce bon rooney
a imaginé la structure interne de la
terre mais en plus il nous raconte
comment elle s'est formée que c'est un
ancien slate et ça c'est plutôt joli et
originale les originaux ya eu une
tartine de modèles après je vous épargne
les détails juste vous raconter mon
petit préféré qu'a été conçu par un
certain gauthier un ingénieur des ponts
et chaussées qui a vécu au xviiie siècle
pour lui la terre étaient creuses et à
l'intérieur il y avait exactement le
même monde en symétrie en fait il était
séparé de nous par une couche de 5 km
d'épaisseur une croûte terrestre c'est
approximativement la distance entre
dessiner mes yeux et cette couche là
elle est maintenue en équilibre par deux
forces opposées la gravité est une force
qui provient de la rotation de la tête
et du cou il pourrait y avoir de la vie
à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur de la
terre un peu comme comment un testicule
géant si c'est pas enthousiasmant comme
idée c'est en tout cas un peu plus
qu'une crotte de nez technologique on en
voit le bout de
l'univers imaginé que si ça se trouve ya
un autre vous qui vit sa vie en ce
moment même sous vos pieds vous avez un
double souterrain je passais dogues
je me demande en tout cas ce qu'il est
en train de faire en ce moment votre
double et vous qu'est ce que vous êtes
en train de faire à regarder une vidéo
de géologie de votre plein gré venez
vous confier dans les commentaires en
plus youtube a implémenté un nouvel
outil de suggestion automatique de
réponse tout à fait au point que je
m'engage solennellement à l'utiliser dès
qui me proposera en réponse de vos
commentaires des réponses toutes faites
allez y lâchez vous et pour finir avec
cette histoire de terre creuse ce que je
trouve absolument fascinant c'est
d'essayer d'imaginer à quoi
ressemblerait plus sérieusement les
civilisations en dessous comment elle
serait évoluer dans un monde sans soleil
quelle serait leur source d'énergie est
ce qu'elle aurait de la lumière j'ai
beaucoup trop de baffes dans la bouche
la nuit elle verrait pas la voûte
étoilée elle verrait gens les voisins
d'en face quoi ça ressemblera paris bref
maintenant qu'on a un cadre théorique
solide
merci les filles rsa on va pouvoir voir
en pratique à quoi ressemble l'intérieur
de la terre et ça on l'a appris en
creusant du coup parce qu'on peut pas
aller bien loin on l'a vu à non plus en
coupant la planète avec un couteau ou un
fils à bord assez grand parce que
l'existant pas encore que fait le
concours lépine
alors qu'est ce qu'il nous reste comme
aux petits déjà on peut regarder les
affleurements parfois quand des
montagnes se plissent elle la peau de
votre char paye quand ces fabricants le
dégonfle avant de vous livrer le deux
propriétaires le savent mais en fait
quand vous recevez votre shar peï à la
maison il faut leur bon flair ne faut
pas le laisser comme ça et donc quand
les montagnes se plissent elle remonte
en surface du matériel qui est issu des
profondeurs et qu'on peut observer tout
gentiment en promenant son shar-peï en
l'occurrence regonfler que ce soit dans
les pyrénées ou dans les alpes par
exemple et donc c'est comme ça qu'on a
appris que le manteau terrestre était
vert parce qu'il est composé de
péridotite une roche bourg et d'olivier
on appelle aussi péridot la vie est bien
mais même si c'est déjà super de savoir
ce qu'il ya dans le manteau on ne
trouvera jamais de cailloux qui est plus
profond que ça donc qu'est-ce qu'un en
dessous ne ménageons pas le suspense
plus longtemps on peut procéder avec la
terre comme avec votre employé enfin ne
pas renouveler son cdd et faire une
échographie pour voir ce qu'elle a dans
le ventre et un peu politisés cette
vidéo comme et pour faire cette
échographie de la terre ou l'écoutent
vibrer changement d'ambiance
nous sommes en l'an mil neuf cent
soixante dix le pérou est secoué par un
séisme qui provoque un glissement de
terrain ensevelissant littéralement un
village etc
vingt mille moore 2004 à sumatra un
tremblement de terre suivi d'un tsunami
tueur à 230 milles âmes
2010une secousses à port-au-prince en
haïti fera 316 mille morts autant qu'il
y as d'habitants à nantes ou à nice
eh ben ça c'est du pain béni pour les
géologues oui ils ont un coeur de pierre
c'est bon gros séisme là ils vont
produire des ondes qui vont parcourir
toute la planète et du coup ils vont
nous permettre de faire enfin cette
fameuse échographique bon ça marche
aussi avec les petits séismes mignon la
mêlée gros ils produisent des ondes plus
intense qui du coup vont aller plus loin
parce qu'elle s'est ténue mois à moins
rapidement et voilà
ringo c'est comme ça que les sismologues
arrive à cartographier l'intérieur de la
planète jusqu'à son bill les
tremblements de terre mais avant d'aller
plus loin une page de réclame
un impact une fissure c'est du quartz
s'il ne partait plus brûle figurez-vous
je mets ma casquette publicitaire là que
la famille d'une amie complètement folle
de jeu dans kate a lancé un financement
participatif pour un jeu que je trouve
assez cool son nom script sa passion les
énigmes son ennemi juré
les fruits c'est une série qui contient
plusieurs collections la première
s'intitule roman noir avec déjà deux
enquêtes mystères à hollywoodland à la
mort de votre grand-père vous découvrez
une mystérieuse boîte pleine de photos
articles et documents consacrés à sa
mère célèbre actrice hollywoodienne des
années 40 mais votre arrière grand mère
cacher un lourd secret qui vous changera
à jamais le découvrir il vous faudra
plonger dans l'âge d'or d'hollywood
donc ça c'est un jeu d'enquêté classique
dans une boîte à faire le dimanche aprèm
seul ou avec des amis si vous avez et la
deuxième enquête c'est la famille au
rugby le riche industriel you and run
ball est mort l'année dernière de
malades mais en anonyme vous envoie
avoue célèbre détective un appel à
l'aide pour lui c'est un meurtre aidé de
votre ami policier
vous remonterez jusqu'aux origines de la
famille cruz borg pour retrouver le
crime y est c'est pour les gros joueurs
qui ont envie d'être acteurs de
l'histoire d'interroger les suspects
tous à vous pouvez même leur mentir ou
leur réciter les versets de la bible
puisque leurs réponses ne sont pas
automatiques elles sont faites sur
mesure par des petits enfants
pakistanais qui veulent arrondir leurs
fins de mois après avoir fini de coudre
des baskets après cette collection roman
noir du coup il y aura d'autres
collections aventure thriller horreur et
géologie mais ça c'est encore en
négociation avec eux mais j'y prends si
ce projet vous plaît n'hésitez pas à le
soutenir et à partager leurs pages ulule
vous avez jusqu'à fin mai donc c'est
tout bientôt pour participer alors faut
pas traîner allez hop hop hop pourquoi
je fais ça fait allez on reprend or donc
c'est grâce aux séismes conseil
vaguement ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur de
la terre et ça c'est grâce surtout à une
propriété magique des ondes sismiques
écoutez bien leur vitesse dépend de la
densité du matériau qu'elle traverse
en gros plus la roche est dense plus les
ondes vous vite à travers donc on a
planté des sismographes aux quatre coins
de la terre et en fonction du temps
qu'une onde sismique va mettre à aller
faire vibrer chaque à bas on peut
reconstituer sa trajectoire et du coup
la vitesse de l'undd et donc avoir une
idée du matériau qu'elle traverse c'est
aussi simple que ça et c'est comme ça
qu'on arrive à
tracer le trajet d'une onde sismique je
trouve ça très cool d'ailleurs que
l'instrument un sismographe en gros
c'est comme si vous avez un stylo
suspendue au dessus de rien il ya une
faille en dessous et le stylo ne bouge
pas mais quand il ya un séisme c'est la
fin qui bouge avec la terre et du coup
c'est là que le stylo va faire de l'art
c'est assez cool comme truc non bon
maintenant qu'on sait comment on sait à
peu près qu'à son au pied il reste plus
qu'à vous y emmener pour ça je vous
propose une petite expérience de pensée
on va faire un voyage au centre de la
terre c'est une idée révolutionnaire ça
faut que j'écrive un bouquin là dessus
ça trop bien souvent là et tant qu'on y
est dans l'est dans les idées
révolutionnaires oublie pas de vous
abonner à cette chaîne vidéo avoue que
3500 15 2 % des gens qui regardent mes
vidéos ne sont pas abonnés l'êtes vous
êtes vous soyez le russe qui creusent et
non pas celui qui abandonne et qui
empoisonne ses opposants pelé alors
voilà vous incarnez une onde sismique
vous êtes une onde vous voyager à vélo
ça avoue par les salles et beaubourg
donc vous chevauchez votre vélo vintage
avec un cageot à l'arrière qui est
fabriqué avec des palettes pour
transporter vos points forts et les
points où vous avez pris à la map mais
vous allez juste laisser pourrir au fond
du bac à billère de votre frigo pendant
que vous irez au kfc comme tout vous de
viser gaiement sur un petit chemin
caillouteux ça c'est vous qui vous
enfoncer dans la croûte terrestre vous
fais l'aller gaiement vous êtes contents
vous êtes une onde heureuse ne sentez
pas il se met à faire chaud et qu'il y a
corner de roche de plus en plus
volumineux qui pèse de plus en plus
lourds au dessus de votre tête parce que
vous en savez rien vous vous êtes juste
une ça vous touche pas vous ne fait que
passer vous fait vibrer les cailloux tel
jimi hendrix à woodstock durant son solo
de guitare iconique dans lequel ils
imitent les bombardements de b52 pendant
la guerre du vietnam référence
nécessaire donc l'histoire de pression
et tout ça vous touche pas directement
mais ça fait quand même que quand la
pression augmente la roche devient de
plus en plus dense et du coup vous vous
allez pouvoir voyager de plus en plus
rapidement l'intérieur de cette roche
donc en gros ça va être de plus en plus
facile de pédaler pour vous un peu comme
si vous étiez en descente comme un
youtuber mainstream quelques heures
après avoir pris son rail quand soudain
en dessous d'un an soudan soudain vous
avez parcouru à peu près une trentaine
de kilomètres et brusquement le petit
chemin caillouteux devient une belle
piste cyclable vous avez bien fait voter
écolo municipal a en fait vous venait de
franchir une discontinuité sismique
c'est quand d'un coup on change de
matériaux vous venez de quitter la
croûte et d'entrer dans le manteau point
de basalte fneich ou gabbro maintenant
c'est le royaume de la péridotite qui
n'en parlais tout à l'heure alors la
profondeur de cette discontinuité et
variable si vous
parti du fond de l'océan où vous aurez
seulement parcouru 8 km à peu près et si
vous partez d'une montagne c'est plus 60
km mais disons qu'en moyenne la limite
croûte mentaux et autour des 30 km et
cette limite
elle a été découverte en 1909 à ses
récents quand même par un certain moreau
vidosic d'où son nom la discontinuité de
mots rohfritsch où le mot pour les
intimes on continue sur notre belle
piste cyclable en descente
oui [ __ ] gaiement on se sent bien on
se sent bien on se sent bien et d'un
coup la piste est moins carrossables il
ya des nids-de-poule vous traversé une
zone de basses vélocité où elle vz c'est
l'asthénosphère la sphère mode en gros
c'est une partie plus molle du manteau
qui est située entre 60 et 220 km de
profondeur alors il ya plein de trucs
qu'on ignore sur cette couche en est
même pas sûr qu'elles existent partout
sur terre c'est pas trop non plus
pourquoi elle est plus molle que le rêve
c'est de la roche solide déjà tu
démontes l'idée reçue que sous nos pieds
il y aurait des plaques tectoniques qui
sortent sur un océan de magma sefyu vous
pouvez l'oublier en fait la roche est
tellement compris mais elle subit de
telles pressions à ces profondeurs que
même si elle voulait être liquide et bah
elle pourrait par contre en remontant la
elle peut devenir liquide puisque la
pression des mines et donc on pense que
certains volcans serait due justement à
une remontée de panache mantellique
depuis 7 à sténo sphère vers la surface
et c'est ce qui causerait ce qu'on
appelle le volcanisme de points chauds
comme à la réunion où jadis peut être
même notre massif central oui le massif
central était peut-être un point chaud
peut-être donc on ne sait pas trop
pourquoi cette à sténo sphère est molle
dit ductile pour faire chic ça peut être
parce qu'une toute petite partie serait
effectivement fondu de l'ordre de 1% ou
alors elle serait globalement à la
limite du point de fusion mais tellement
comprimés que du coup elle resterait
solide et elle sera un peu dans un état
intermédiaire 2 je suis solide mais j'ai
quand même envie de me comporter comme
un liquide bref reprenez vous traversez
seigner poule et vous retrouvez
maintenant une belle piste cyclable bien
carrossées j'aurais jamais autant
utilisé donc vous continuez à traverser
le manteau terrestre vous pédalez vous
pédalez sur votre joli pis là ça va plus
à descendre que vous allez vite plus
vous vous prenez pour un coureur du tour
de france en train de dévaler le pic de
la truite en normandie et là paf vous
prenez un mur de plein fouet bienvenu
dans le noyau externe
ce mur c'est la limite berlin est et
berlin ouest entre le manteau et le
noyau terrestre enfin vous êtes arrivé
au coeur de notre planète c'est là où
personne n'était jamais allée enfin le
tour du coeur
nous a freinés direct c'est parce qu'il
est liquide ce conte alors faut que nous
avons un truc je suis fan de joe dassin
est en fait y'a pas un mais deux types
d'ondés sismiques qui traversent la
terre les ondes b qui sont l'enjeu tue
din al et les ondes s qui sont
cisaillant il est s sont incapables de
traverser des liquides elles savent pas
nager et du coup si elle arrive jusqu'au
noyau externe elles sont coupé net dans
leur élan et à disparaissent si vous
êtes une honte paix par contre vous
pouvez soit être déviée on réfléchit au
niveau du mur et repartir d'où vous
venez ou bien vous prenez votre courage
à deux mains vous sautez dans la gadoue
et vous la traversée à la nage avec
votre vélo sur le dos façon mode d ouais
vous pensiez juste sortir pour faire un
tour à la friperie du coin et paf on
vous emmène pour un triller à tout c'est
sa relation et là vous avez beau être
matinal
vous avez mal de traverser un océan de
fer et de nickel fondu mais il faut pas
en vouloir aux maillots externe pour ça
parce que ce marais c'est à lui que vous
devez la vie à lui que vous devez la vie
de vos parents de votre double
souterrain des levures de votre bière
des mycoses que vous avez entre les
doigts de pied et oui c'est grâce au
noyau externe que la terre un champ
magnétique ont fait cette espèce détente
de métal liquide hibou et en moins comme
ça il va en bout en bout y en bref il va
générer à un champ magnétique autour de
la terre c'est une dynamo auto excité
comme moi même je l'appris qui est ce
champ magnétique agit comme un bouclier
qui nous protège du vent solaire des
pelletées de particules dégueulasse que
le soleil nous envoie dessus en
permanence et qui sont très nocives à la
vie donc dit merci à cette piscine de
métal fondu de vous protéger du vomi
solaire dites-le j'attends et continuer
à nager aussi jusqu'à ce que vous voyez
se dessiner à l'horizon ni l'eau mais
revêt cette île c'est le noyau interne
la graine
elle est aussi constituée de fer et de
nickel mais cette fois sous forme solide
et pas liquides et plus ça va plus la
terre se refroidit au fil des milliards
d'années donc plus la graine va grossir
et prendre la place du noyau externe
et quand il y aura plus du tout de noyau
externe les bars ne sais pas ce qu'il va
se passer en fait sans doute que nous on
sera plus là pour le voir mais peut-être
nous double souterrain cela dit vous
vous arrêtez pas en si bon chemin non
non vous êtes une honte donc vous avez
beau être arrivé à destination
vous continuez à tokyo japon traverse la
graine repart se mouiller les mollets et
hop on escalade le mur pouvait même
atteindre la croûte à nouveau si jamais
vous êtes du manoir rebondir là dessus
et repartir dans l'autre sens
et oui traversait la rue ça vous suffit
pas vous voulez carrément traverser la
terre c'est l'esprit français c'est tout
à votre honneur
et voilà donc comment c'est ce qui se
cache dans les entrailles de notre bonne
estaires sans l'ouvrir en devant les
coûts tant vibrer l'histoire ne dit pas
si ça marche aussi pour voir l'intérieur
des gens atteints de la maladie de
parkinson
et le pire c'est qu'on a vraiment juste
une vague idée de ce qu à l'intérieur de
la terre est encore plein de subtilité
qu'on continue de découvrir au fur et à
mesure par exemple le manteau n'est pas
du tout homogène on découvre des régions
de basse vélocité comme l'asthénosphère
qu'on a vu au début la les nids-de-poule
donc en fait quand je vous parle d'une
piste cyclable parfaitement carrossables
et bah c'est pas tout à fait vrai il ya
certains chemins qui sont plus sympas
que d'autres et des chercheurs pense
même avoir trouvé les vestiges d'une
ancienne planète aujourd'hui disparue
celle que la terre aurait percuté
pendant sa prime jeunesse pour aboutir à
la création de la lui voilà rien que ça
donc il y aurait des restes de l'autre
planète à l'intérieur de l'anneau un peu
comme si on avait absorbé notre jumeaux
siamois dans le ventre de notre mère et
qui en fait on se baladait avec ses
organes à l'intérieur et figurez vous
que ce qu'on a fait là des chercheurs
sont en train de faire la même chose
aussi sur mars en 2018 des chercheurs de
l'institut de physique du globe ont posé
un sismomètre sur mars qui s'appelle
saiss et son but c'est justement de
comprendre l'intérieur de la planète
grâce au seuil et oui il ya aussi des
séismes sur mars ça permettrait aussi de
comprendre d'où venait le champ
magnétique martien qui a disparu
aujourd'hui la fia plein plein plein de
questions sans réponses encore un
sentiment qu exprime pleinement ce
proverbe traditionnelle russe mis à ça
[Musique]
merci au type heures et surtout bonne
année si vous avez aimé cette vidéo vous
aimerez sans doute la chaîne sous nos
pieds qui parle de géologie de manière
beaucoup plus poétique et poser
n'hésitez pas à les voir d'ailleurs je
le remercie d'avoir reçu le script de
cette présente vidéo n'hésitez pas à a
contribué à partager le projet ulule de
ma potins et aussi j'ai lancé ma
boutique en ligne pas plus tôt mais
boutique en ligne en a une sur youtube
et une sur dix spring mais magnifique
descend donc si je mets vous voulez
jeter un oeil mais vous sentez pas
obligé d'acheter quelque chose ne
pouvait juste admirer moi ça me va très
bien
et si cette vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez
aller voir cette dégustation de
bouillabaisse ou ce défilé de manchots
en salopette